comment apprendre à faire sur votre
ancien grand patron j'ai gagné un
concours
le président n'a pas péché de monsieur
gary par téléphone
vous avez une chance unique
envie de vous rencontrer nathan one même
kaleme
on peut oublier ces histoires
d'employeurs en pleine santé et pourra
constater que ce bâtiment n'est pas une
maison c'est un centre de recherche
je voudrais te parler de la plus grandes
inventions scientifiques de l'histoire
de l'humanité
tu développes unia bonjour salut je
n'avais jamais rencontré quelqu'un de
nouveau
et toi personne comme toi elle est
incroyable le test c'est de te l'a
présenté en tant que robot et de voir si
tu penses toujours qu'elle a une
conscience tu veux être un ennemi
oui bien sûr ça sera possible
pourquoi ça ne serait pas tu n'es jamais
sortis d'ici on pourrait sortir ensemble
tu l'a programmé pour qu'elle flirte
avec moi
il paraît que de penser à moi si tu mens
je le saurai non mans tard elle fait
peut-être semblant de s'attacher à toi
et pour quelle raison je crois qu'on
peut me débrancher
ça ne dépend pas de moi pourquoi ses
dépens de quelqu'un tu devrais te méfier
de nathan tu devrais te méfier de tout
ce qu'il est dit je pense que le
prochain modèle sera la véritable
innovation
tu fais quoi de l'ancien il faut que tu
m'aides un jour les i à nous
considérerons comme des singes se tenant
debout fin prêt pour l'extinction
c'est étrange d'avoir créé quelque chose
qui te déteste je faisais quoi avec abba